einen schönen guten abend willkommen zu
unserem live stream zu heute live mit
dem thema trotz corona zurück auf die
bühne das wäre schön für viele in der
veranstaltungsbranche droht der in
corona zeiten vielen menschen die pleite
oder sie ist schon da und aus diesem
grunde wird am sonntag in mehreren
großstädten demonstriert das ganze per
autocorso organisiert vom bündnis
hashtag alarmstufe rot denn am sonntag
ist es genau ein jahr her dass die
ersten veranstaltungen von den behörden
eben wegen corona verboten werden
mussten
welche möglichkeiten gibt es die größten
probleme abzuwenden und was fordern
kunst und kultur eigentlich und was
bietet der staat ihnen an ist das
ausreichend darüber sprechen wir mit the
bosshoss kultbands mit großen hits
derzeit im tonstudio in berlin und ihr
könnt wie immer gerne mitmachen und eure
fragen und kommentare an die bekannte
adresse schicken zunächst aber zu
unseren gästen zu the bosshoss oder
bürgerlich und sascha servus in die
runde schön dass ihr dabei seid und
service auch ihr macht mit bei dieser
initiative
wie ist das bei euch persönlich wie ist
eure alarmstufe ist ja auch schon gut
wie habt ihr das letzte jahr empfunden
aber die frustration stufe ist rot mehr
als dunkelrot sogar ein jahr
berufsverbot ist natürlich hart und es
macht uns aus sorge vor allem das es ja
so aussieht als ob es noch lange nicht
zu ende ist genau das das problem die
perspektive wir haben unsere tour von 19
in 20 verschoben und sind jetzt dabei in
21 zu schieben und da ist noch ein
langer weg dahin und da kann noch viel
passieren und wir hoffen natürlich dass
wir irgendwann wieder auf die bühne
kommen ja aber das bringt mich dann
sozusagen direkt zu meiner ersten
userinnen frage in dem fall weil nadine
weber über facebook fragt tatsächlich
wird euro tour von der gerade gesprochen
habt noch mal verschoben oder komplett
abgesagt wenn sie dieses jahr nicht
stattfindet findet viele fans sitzen auf
ihrem geld der tickets schreibt sie ja
das ist ein dilemma für uns alle
natürlich genauso wie für uns wie für
die fans
so wie es aussieht wir bemühen uns
gerade sehr darum es von diesem geklagt
im sommer in den nächsten zu schieben
und hoffen dass uns das erst mal so
gelingt dass wir wirklich alle termine
wahrnehmen können die tickets behalten
die gültigkeit und wir hoffen auch sehr
dass die fans noch so lange durchhalten
können und das verständnis haben auf uns
zu warten weil das natürlich auch für
uns nicht leicht ist irgendwie machen
das natürlich nicht freiwillig mit
müssen wir haben den stufenplan gesehen
und der sieht keine veranstaltungen in
unserer größenordnung vor
bis weit in den spätsommer und da bleibt
uns gar nichts anderes übrig als zu
schieben und zu hoffen dass die fans an
der stange bleiben und die tickets
behalten weil die verlieren nicht ihre
gültigkeit und wir wollen das auf jeden
fall nach das ist doch gut dass wir die
gelegenheit ja schon mal nutzen können
um darauf hinzuweisen wir sprechen auch
gleich noch über stufen pläne aber
vielleicht vorher nochmal an euch die
frage ja womit haltet ihr euch dann der
zeit künstlerisch so bei laune gibt es
da irgendwelche alternativen zu
konzerten macht ihr streams eventuell
oder wie sieht es aus bei laune halten
es wurde gut gestellte frage also wir
versuchen die lange oben zu halten
im moment sind wir im studio und
arbeiten einem neuen songs das ist
letztendlich auch das einzige was uns
geblieben ist was wir machen können
derzeit weil die live situation ist
bekannt da erinnert sich auch so schnell
nichts und alternativen gibt es nicht
wirklich
ja also das streaming ist toll das
machen wir hier auch öfter mal aus dem
studio werden es sicher noch mal machen
vielleicht manchmal auch so gaben ein
bezahltes streaming event wo man auch
ticket kaufen kann da arbeiten wir
natürlich daran müssen wir daran
arbeiten aber das ersetzt natürlich bei
weitem keine tour
wenn man 60 termine hat oder 60 tage am
stück unterwegs ist kann man nicht mit
einem streaming event auch wiegen
erstens fühlt sich das nicht sogar an
und zweitens denkt man nicht auch an
unsere kunden unsere leute da hinten
dahinter hinter der bühne die uns höher
und sehbar machen die haben 60 tage zu
tun und beim streaming event halt nur
ein davon können die nicht überleben ich
habe gerade schon das thema öffnungs
pläne angesprochen es ist viel davon die
rede auch von
perspektiven die leute wollen gerne alle
irgendwie perspektiven haben wie es
weitergehen soll das gilt natürlich auch
für die kultur schaffen denn man hört
aber auch viel von von schulen in diesem
zusammenhang oder auch vom einzelhandel
von von reisen habt ihr das gefühl dass
die kultur seitens der der politik da
manchmal ein bisschen hinten runterfällt
na ja es ist natürlich problematisch zum
einen gibt es logischerweise wichtigere
dinge noch als die kultur schulen über
das gerade angesprochen stehen natürlich
ganz ganz oben und ansonsten sitzen ja
alle irgendwie im selben boot das
problem der kultur ist natürlich dass
wir vom publikumsverkehr leben und dass
wir das konzerte theaterbesuche
kinobesucher halt davon leben dass
möglichst viele menschen zusammen kultur
genießen können das ist halt das problem
und so wie es gerade aussieht wird das
natürlich eins der letzten dinge sein
was wieder zur normalität zurück gibt
und wo ist der riesen branche ist nun da
wundert man sich immer also ein wirklich
starker starker umsatz wird durch die
veranstaltungs industrie generiert ja
hohe steuergelder also ein wichtiger
industriezweig und ich verstehe
natürlich alle und ich gönne jedem
restaurant und jeder schule und jedem
reisebüro und allen die davon betroffen
sind dass sie möglichst schnell wieder
land sehen und auch öffnen können
aber man liest jeden tag in der zeitung
oder in den nachrichten ist immer der
friseur die als die einzelhandel der
restaurantbesuche von der branche von
der kulturbranche liest man nichts
deswegen sind wir sehr dankbar dass wir
mal im format wie hier zu wort kommen ja
wir können das auch gerne noch mal mit
ein paar zahlen stützen also sechs
größte wirtschaftszweig mehr als eine
million beschäftigte was jetzt die
kulturbranche beziehungsweise die
veranstaltungsbranche angeht 130
milliarden euro umsatz pro jahr
oder waren es millionen musste ich
zeigen wir nachreichen auf jeden fall
eine riesige ja und ja richtig viel geld
und insofern glaube ich ist das durchaus
berechtigt was ihr da gerade gesagt hab
ich würde gerne nochmal die politik mit
ins boot holen viel hoffnung nach die
nämlich momentan nicht was die
wiederaufnahme von konzerten angeht der
spd gesundheitsexperte karl lauterbach
hat sich dazu da uns geäußert wenn es
uns
link die drei risikogruppen zu impfen
flächendeckend zu ins und das wird ende
juni der fall sein
spätestens dann also kann man sicherlich
war durch schritte erwägen
bis dahin muss man bei großen
veranstaltungen bei
kulturveranstaltungen schlichtweg
gefährlich sagt wir mussten mehr geld in
die hand genommen werden die
veranstalter müssen großzügiger
unterstützt werden wir müssen in
rechnung tragen dass es jetzt schon so
lange anhält
aber wir dürfen nicht den fehler machen
dass wir eine große gruppe von besonders
gefährdet sind das sind es insbesondere
die 50 bis 80 jährigen die welt noch
nicht impfen konnten dass wir diese
gruppe gefährden weil einfach die dritte
welle darüber was wegrollt also sind
natürlich 130 milliarden ich hatte das
auch richtig im kopf hat es mir falsch
aufgeschrieben also wirklich eine große
branche
jetzt haben wir gerade karl lauterbach
gehört und da lautet das fazit ja im
prinzip also auftritte im moment
eigentlich nicht möglich stattdessen
mehr kohle an die künstler ist dass die
perspektive die jetzt die skills und
weiter gelten muss ich also wir sind
natürlich realistisch natürlich steht
dann steht gesundheitsschutz nach wie
vor an erster stelle und es gibt glaube
ich auch nicht darum dass wir oder
andere in der kulturbranche sagen wir
wollen jetzt einfach wieder spielen egal
wie weit wir mit impfungen sind oder wie
das funktioniert das ist klar immer im
vordergrund das problem ist was er
angesprochen hat die hilfe die wir halt
wirklich schön wenn die wirklich nicht
nur immer besprochen wird sondern
tatsächlich auch mal irgendwo ankommt
ich erinnere mich dass wir im letzten
sommer mit alarmstufe roten riesen demo
in berlin gemacht haben in mehreren
städten in deutschland wurde auf die
situation aufmerksam gemacht haben wie
wie dramatisch ist wirklich finanziell
um die vielen vielen verschiedenen
bereiche in der kulturbranche das fängt
ja beim veranstalter an und hört beim
solo selbstständigen beim solo künstler
techniker auf es wird immer viel
versprochen aber es ist ein riesen
bürokratiemonster auf alle losgelassen
worden was einfach ja die sache wirklich
nicht einfacher gemacht hat und wenn ich
jetzt höre dass es bis juni andauern
wird sind wir realistisch genug glaube
ich um es klar zu machen dass das
vielleicht sogar noch länger dauern wird
wir uns die situation in deutschland
angucken dann ist das natürlich schön zu
hören wenn man sagt man müsste mehr geld
in die hand nehmen
ich glaube nur nicht mehr dran ja und
vor allem darf nicht vergessen wir
wollen das gar nicht auf uns beziehen
wir sind fast 20 jahre im business wir
haben uns etwas aufgebaut wir haben auch
was zurück gelegt also wir wollen gar
nicht meckern oder so wir kommen schon
irgendwie klar wir gucken in die zukunft
und sagen irgendwann geht es wieder los
und greifen dann da an wo wir aufhören
mussten aber die kultur ist er so
vielfältig und die wächst vom nachwuchs
also nach uns kommen ja kleine band so
wie wir auch angefangen haben die müssen
erst mal auf die bühne und spielen
spielen spielen die müssen ihr publikum
erreichen
und wenn denen die möglichkeit genommen
wird dass sie das nicht tun dann haben
wir ein cut dann machen wir hier weiter
und hören irgendwann auf und der
nachwuchs fehlt die kleinen künstler die
kleinen bands die kleinen schauspieler
und so weiter den wird der boden unter
den füßen gezogen um auf ihren zukunft
zu bauen und auf ihren beruf zu schauen
und da ist es richtig was an europas
sagt wir brauchen unterstützung ist ganz
ganz wichtig weil kultur für eine
gesellschaft ist nicht zu unterschätzen
auch unsere user martin müller über
facebook schreibt was helfen kann
fragezeichen nahe groß geschrieben
hilfsprogramme sonst wird nicht viel
viel kultur übrig bleiben also bleiben
wir noch mal ganz kurz bei den
hilfsprogrammen auch dazu haben wir ein
bisschen was vorbereitet ist ist geld
geflossen staatlicherseits also man kann
jetzt nicht sagen dass da gar nichts
gezahlt würde aber die frage ist halt
eben reicht das aus wir gucken uns noch
ein paar fakten an mein kollege heiko
kunzmann hat die zusammengetragen
seit monaten geht das hier nicht mehr
groß veranstaltungen und konzerte
alles abgesagt und das heißt oft keine
auftritte kein geld denn viele in dieser
branche sind freiberufler mit dem
programm neustart kultur wollte der bund
noch vor dem zweiten shut down helfen
mit einer milliarde euro für die
kulturbranche von dem geld profitieren
vor allem museen clubs festivals oder
kinos gerade kam eine weitere milliarde
dazu zentraler topf für firmen und auch
selbstständige sind die sogenannten
überbrückungshilfen hier werden
fixkosten zuschüsse gezahlt je nachdem
wie hoch die umsatzeinbußen sind doch
die jazz musikern und fotografen etwa
bringt dieses programm nur wenig für sie
gibt es jetzt die sogenannte neustart
hilfe eingeführt für solo selbständige
mit geringen fixkosten einmalig bekommen
sie bis zu 7500 euro abhängig vom
jahresumsatz 2009 10
teilweise bieten auch die länder hilfen
an um die kunst und kultur zu erhalten
also julia fliegen hat er auch noch
mitgemacht bei diesen beitrag deswegen
die angenehme stimme aber jetzt nochmal
zurück zum eigentlichen thema also es
ist wie gesagt geld geflossen aber wie
bewertet ihr das also gerade jetzt auch
der letzte punkt mit der neustadt hilfe
7500 euro pro person
habt ihr den eindruck dass das ausreicht
für die gegenwärtige problematik nein
das heißt nicht aus also das kann man
ganz klar beantworten ja also das ist
besser als gar nicht das ist schon mal
gut aber es reicht nicht aus man muss
sich ja vorstellen
die leute sind seit einem jahr
arbeitslos sie mussten sich irgendwo
geld leihen oder zurückschrauben oder
haben ihren landlord nach mit stundung
gefragt oder was auch immer so jetzt
kriegen sie 7500 euro haben vielleicht
familie und kinder
eine mietwohnung und müssten jetzt
eigentlich mal was zurückzahlen von der
vergangenheit wie sie es sich
verschuldet haben und jetzt soll aber
diese neustadt hilfe von januar bis juni
gelten uns das ist
eindeutig zu wenig und dann ist auch
nicht klar ob sie es behalten dürfen
werden man jetzt im april noch meinen
job reinkriegt dann muss man schon
wieder anteilig etwas zurück bezahlen
obwohl man eigentlich auf 220 noch auf
die kosten von 220 lebt ich glaube auch
dass die die unglaubliche vielfalt in
der kulturbranche einfach von der
politik nicht verstanden wurde
natürlich ist es schön wenn veranstalter
wenn klubs zuschüsse bekommen eine
wirtschafts hilfe beantragen können die
natürlich auch von vielen vielen hürden
irgendwie gepflastert ist aber der solo
selbstständige wurde gerade im
einspieler angesprochen der einzelne
musiker der fotograf der freiberufler
der hat natürlich von fixkosten
zuschüssen gar nichts weil er meistens
gar keine fixkosten hat und von
irgendwas leben muss man ja auch und es
ist ja einfach die situation was wir
auch ein bisschen als gesellschaftliche
ungerechtigkeit empfinden der lotter und
betrifft alle ja aber vom berufsverbot
also auf 0 1 kommen runter geschraubt
wurden hat einfach nur wenige und die
kultur ist sehr betroffen und ich denke
dass 7.500 euro und das heißt ja bis zu
das heißt das ist das maximum was man
erhalten kann und wir reden dann wie
sascha sagt über nahezu 15 16 monate
berufsverbote bleibt letztendlich ein
hartz4 regelsatz übrig wenn man ihn denn
bekommt und das ist unserer meinung nach
nicht ausreichend nicht ausreichend
arbeit so habe ich immerhin auch ein
lauterbach jetzt verstanden dass der
durchaus sieht das als er jetzt mal
stellvertretend für die politik in
berlin dass da noch luft nach oben sein
muss und das auch noch mehr geld in die
hand genommen werden muss
wir gucken jetzt gerade nochmal auf
eurer homepage beziehungsweise auf die
von alarmstufe rot dort ort denn das ist
ganz schön ihr habt da auch einige also
ich sage jetzt einfach mal ihr aber eben
eure initiative einige forderungen
aufgelistet das geht sogar ziemlich ins
detail also was ihr da konkret fordert
das kann man sich hier mal anschauen da
geht es unter anderem ich würde ziemlich
in die einzelheiten einsteigen aber es
geht um überbrückungs programme
es geht um kreditprogramme steuerliche
erleichterungen und
kurzarbeiterregelungen um noch mal ein
paar beispiele zu nennen habt ihr denn
das gefühl dass etwas davon
bei der politik durchdringt gibt es da
einen konstruktiven dialog
so hören die euch gehen darauf ein ich
glaube dass das einfach nicht im detail
geführt wird also das ist natürlich
gehört wird und auch gesehen und auch
verstanden wird das ist ja auch
irgendwie logisch und würde uns ja auch
entsetzen wenn in der politik wie man
sagt das ist nicht nicht verständlich
ich glaube nur dass es in der umsetzung
einfach nicht vorwärts geht und ich
denke auch dass das besprochen wurde und
man ist auch im austausch aber was in
deutschland wirklich ein problem ist es
einfach die bürokratie und dann würde
man sich einfach wünschen dass in einer
notsituation unkompliziert vorschüsse
gezahlt werden abschläge auf häfen man
kann auch später gucken dass ich glaube
niemand sinnlos geld ausgeben man kann
das auch später alles prüfen ob
vernünftig auf mein anspruch hatte aber
es muss halt was passieren und man kann
halt nicht monate brauchen bis man
überhaupt anträge stellen darf dann sind
die regularien so schwierig dass ich wir
kennen zum beispiel niemand in unserem
umfeld der ohne einen steuerberater in
der lage war einen antrag zu stellen und
das zeigt schon mal wie wie viele hürden
einfach zu nehmen sind und das ist
einfach nicht okay und es ist auf jeden
fall total komplex ich verstehe das auch
dass es schwierig ist dafür den weg zu
finden
aber deswegen ändert sich halt auch
andauernd was na ja auch selbst
steuerberater sagt naja also genau
wissen wir haben wir zwar stand jetzt
aber wir können jetzt nicht sagen diese
nächste woche aussieht oder nächsten
monat also man muss immer wieder neu
eintauchen in die materie und wenn man
sie jetzt vorstellt ich sag mal normaler
musiker der sein geld bisher von vom
musikmachen verdient uns jetzt nicht so
ein fuchs ist und papiertiger der steigt
da nicht durch wenn selbst denn selbst
versteuern berater da extra jemand
einstellt oder run setzte er sich nur um
die thematik kümmern
es ist wie exakt viel zu komplex und da
bleiben so viele auf der strecke die gar
nicht ankommen selbst wenn sie die hilfe
in anspruch nehmen oder den anspruch
hätten auf die hilfe da
haltet ihr sozusagen unterstützung von
baschi bei uns über youtube die hilfen
sind leider für einen großteil der
betroffenen gar nicht abrufbar gewesen
schreibt er meinen gesamten erarbeiteten
anspruch auf alg 1 habe ich inzwischen
aufbrauchen müssen dafür war es nicht
gedacht also er offensichtlich auch als
künstler unterwegs
klar also dass bestätigt dass in etwa
was ihr gerade gesagt habe wir wollen
noch mal reinhören was ein anderer
politiker zum thema öffnungen und
perspektiven gesagt hat denn darauf wenn
wir dann gleich zu sprechen kommen wir
hören den wirtschaftsminister peter
altmaier von der cdu ich gehe nach wie
vor davon aus dass es möglich sein wird
unter einhaltung aller
hygienevorschriften und der gebotenen
sorgfalt in den kommenden tagen im
umfeld von ostern auch außengastronomie
zuzulassen bei schönem wetter und in den
an den orten die dafür geeignet sind wir
haben damit im letzten jahr gute
erfahrungen gemacht und es gab auch
ausdrücklich bei den verbänden eine
ganze reihe von stimmen die darauf
hingewiesen haben dass man auch andere
aktivitäten durchaus im freien
durchführen kann
dort wo die gefahr der ansteckung durch
ihre sohle weniger groß ist ja das wäre
dann die frage sozusagen nach den open
air konzerten ist allerdings auch die
frage ob er das damit gemeint hat da
könnte ja die ansteckungsgefahr immer
noch relativ groß sein wir wollen aber
gerade auch noch mal schauen auf eine
ganz interessante zahlenfolge hier bei
unseren politbarometer da haben wir
nämlich auch gefragt in welchem bereich
sollte es zuerst zu lockerungen kommen
und die antworten sehen so aus also 40
prozent der befragten sagen in läden und
geschäften 22% kontakt beschränkungen
also mehr soziale kontakte wieder um
sport kultur freizeit immerhin ein
dritter stelle 20 prozent nur vor
restaurants
sie erlebt ihr das also in eurem umfeld
ich meine klar ihr habt wahrscheinlich
auch kontakt immer noch mit fans und so
weiter also wie empfinden dass eure
anhänger wie sehr vermissen die leute
konzerte und kultur wie wir erlebt ihr
das ist ja das wird natürlich hart
vermisst also ich glaube das ist also
erstmal vorweg zu sagen es ist natürlich
völlig uns fern verschiedenen branchen
gegeneinander auszuspielen was ist
wichtiger
der handel ist genauso wichtig und das
einkaufen gehen wie ein konzert besuchen
oder eben sport zu treiben oder ins
restaurant zu gehen ich will das gar
nicht gegen danach fing ich glaube das
gesellschaftliche leben insgesamt das
kann man da schon irgendwie subsumieren
ist einfach total wichtig für die seele
einer gesellschaft und kultur gehört
natürlich dazu uns freut es total das
natürlich zu hören dass es den menschen
und das merken wir auch im umfeld
wirklich fehlt und das zeigt wie
dringend nötig ist dass wir irgendwie
wieder dahin kommen und ich finde ja
schön wenn herr altmaier die die
hoffnungen schürt dass das schöne wetter
ein bisschen abhilfe schafft aber wenn
das einzige konzept was die politik hat
das schöne wetter ist dann wird uns das
natürlich nicht sehr weit bringen ich
glaub das was wir nach england schauen
oder england ist natürlich wesentlich
weiter vorne was in erster linie mit
impfungen zu tun hat dort plant man den
festivalsommer in diesem jahr und das
frustriert und sind natürlich extrem
weil es nicht nur am virus liegt sondern
es liegt vor allem jetzt daran wie wir
das möglichst schnell auf die kette
kriegen und der hammer zeit leider sehr
ja auch ihr werdet klar darüber hat man
auch am anfang schon gesprochen die
gefahr nicht verleugnen wollen durch das
virus und ich meine jetzt gibt's
natürlich maßnahmen die ergriffen werden
es gibt die impfungen es gibt
schnelltests es gibt alles möglich es
gibt nach wie vor natürlich das gebot
abstand zu halten
wie empfindet ihr dass das virus unter
welchen umständen so zu sagen könntet
ihr euch vorstellen dass er überhaupt
wieder vor publikum gespielt habt euch
da mal darüber gedanken gemacht wie
könnte überhaupt so ein konzept aussehen
dass wieder leute zu euren konzerten
kommen könnten ja so einfach also frage
nicht also ich als die einfachste
antwort darauf wäre insel impfen und
dann ist die gefahr gebannt ich glaube
dass ist das einzige wirkliche mittel
was konzerte in größenordnung wie wir
sie gerne machen möchten wir sie diese
gewohnt sind wieder möglich macht also
ein open air konzert und ein festival
ein konzert mit fünf bis zehntausend
menschen draußen oder im stadion ist
natürlich nur möglich wenn alle
geschützt sind und das geht über in die
alleine sachen sind früher möglich ja
ich genau also wie vorher sagte der
nachwuchs ist ja auch noch da ja die
wollen jetzt nicht bei rock am ring
spielen und
wo es gerne täten aber es gibt ja auch
eine clubkultur und klein kleine
konzerte kleine veranstaltungen und
solange nicht alle geimpft sind solange
es mittel nicht da ist muss man halt
testen und das ist möglich mit 200 leute
im klub reinpassen finde ich wenn man
das konzept hat abstandsregelungen wäre
wer rein will muss getestet werden oder
ist eben geimpft werde durchaus mal ein
konzept das meer erfolgen könnte ich
glaube es braucht langsam auch ein
bisschen bisschen mut mit viel sorgfalt
gepaart natürlich um so langsam stück
weit wieder zu versuchen in einem
normalbetrieb zu kommen dass wir noch
weit entfernt von aber wie sascha sagt
den theaterbesuch mit 200 menschen die
ein schnelltest bekommen die eine maske
tragen wo man pausen macht und lüftet
ich glaube so was ist vorstellbar und
wer auch verantwortbar
so könnte ihm können wir uns zumindest
vorstellen dass man langsam wieder dahin
kommt ein wir brauchen ja auch ne ich
glaube wir alle müssen uns auch wieder
irgendwann daran gewöhnen können
irgendwo hinzugehen weil wir so lange im
lotter und wann was ich glaube nicht
dass man einfach den schalter umlegen
kann am morgen rennt man wieder zu einem
konzert mit 4000 menschen hat uns mit
den menschen haben ja auch sensibilität
entwickelt mittlerweile also ist ja
keiner so doof und schützt sich jetzt
nicht mehr also es gibt immer ein paar
idioten ganz klar aber großteil ist es
jetzt gewohnt uns gelernt und man muss
den leuten halt auch eine
eigenverantwortung übertragen und sagen
kommt ihr wisst schon so ist richtig und
so ist falsch also das kann man den
leuten schon zumuten dass sie jemand
nicht husten tim gefüllten raum geht
einem mundschutz zeigen verantwortung
ist glaube ich das richtige wollte man
kann auch der veranstaltungsbranche
durchaus ein gewisses maß an
eigenverantwortung zu aber in der tat
ist das lag auch gerade gesagt hatte ich
glaube das wird schon also darüber macht
man sich ja auch als einfach normaler
mensch gedanken wenn man das erste mal
wieder auf irgend eine großveranstaltung
ist oder auch sachsen und der kneipe mit
vielen leuten das wird schon ein
komisches gefühl sein
man ist es in der tat ich werde drei
okay was geht jetzt gerade so um mich
herum ab aber daran muss man sich ja
irgendwann wieder gewinn und sollte das
ja auch wir wollen da hat nochmal karl
lauterbach hören weil der
gesundheitsexperte der mann schon kurz
hatten er hat sich auch mal bei uns zum
thema perspektive
es hat und in der tat das stichwort ist
impfen impfen impfen ohne das wird es
nicht gehen
wer sich zum beispiel zeigt dass
geimpfte nicht sich anstecken und auch
nicht ansteckend sind wendig daten dass
das so in zukunft zeigen
dann könnte man auch so tatsächlich es
wahrscheinlich einen privaten anbieter
kaum verbieten wenn der konzerte für
geimpfte die das nachlassen können
anbietet das kann man gleichzeitig dann
kaum verhindern
aber es muss ja erstmal gesichert sein
dass tatsächlich dem vor ansteckungen
führt also davor schützt und tatsächlich
der ansteckung werden mann angesteckt so
nicht weitergeht das wissen wir ja jetzt
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht und wir
wissen auch nicht wie sich die impfstoff
verdauen unterscheiden und für wie lange
ein solcher schutz anhalten sollte wenn
es ihnen dann dann gelb daher kann man
das jetzt noch nicht sagen es kann aber
sagen dass das den ex ginge also das
wäre jetzt sozusagen für den fall
gesprochen dass die impfung tatsächlich
auch vor ansteckung schützt in die
richtung fragt dann auch bei uns über
facebook drohen ganz wir haben ja gerade
die große diskussion eben um das impfen
wie ist es bei euch bosshoss lasst ihr
dann nur noch geimpft rein oder alle
habe ich dann aber schon gedanken
gemacht
wir lassen grundsätzlich jeden zu uns
der möchte aber natürlich ist das eine
schwierige frage also es geht erstmal
darum also wie beide lasst uns natürlich
auch impfen sobald es möglich ist es ist
wichtig dass wir uns impfen lassen weil
ich glaube dass das wirklich der einzige
weg um der gefahr zu werden also um das
virus nach und nach zurückzahlen oder
zumindest um die gefahr zu nehmen und
die besteht natürlich darin wirklich
ernsthaft schwer zu erkranken oder daran
zu sterben und ich glaube dass gegeben
ist dann spricht nichts dagegen auch
wieder konzerte zu machen und dann ist
glaube ich bei einem gewissen maß von
von impfungen der in der breite ist auch
nicht die frage ob jemand geimpftes oder
nicht sondern ich glaub es ist die frage
ob es uns noch als gesellschaft viel
anhaben kann
das gilt in erster linie im griff zu
treten vielleicht noch mal ein paar
ermunternde worte hier auch von
christiane rate bei youtube eine studie
der tu berlin hat das infektionsrisiko
verschiedener szenarien errechnet dabei
kam raus mit hygienemaßnahmen bei
50 prozent auslastung ist ein bruchteil
bei kultur gastro im vergleich zur
schule und büro also das wäre sozusagen
ein plädoyer dafür dass bei geringer
auslastung oder sogar mal heftiger man
da vielleicht irgendwann wieder hin
kommt aber wir haben jetzt gesagt also
mit ihnen muss es verbunden sein
wir wollen gerade nochmal laut dabei
hatten wir schon aber ich genau wollte
euch noch mal die frage stellen weil wir
mit euch im sommer auch schon gesprochen
hatten da gab es auch schon eine
veranstaltung dieses bündnisses
alarmstufe rot
und da hieß es eigentlich schon das ist
fünf vor zwölf damals das war im
september wie spät ist es denn heute so
auf eurer uhr
er ist auf jeden fall deutlich später
wie gesagt bei uns ist alles cool wir
hoffen natürlich wir müssen schon auch
wieder loslegen keine frage also wir
können uns jetzt nicht auf unserem
polster ausruhen bis in alle ewigkeit
erstens müssen wir und zweitens wollen
wir natürlich aber es gibt viele viele
künstler bei denen es jetzt schon nach
12 ich weiß nicht wie es die dann
möglich machen irgendeinen weg findet
sich wohl immer sich so durchzumogeln
aber irgendwann ist als die uhr
abgelaufen und das ist auf jeden fall
schon zu spüren auch in unserem umfeld
dass leute die branche wechseln das was
anderes machen dass sie mit dazu
beitragen müssen dass die kultur stirbt
gleich so dramatisch
blackikun ganz kurz fragt noch auf
youtube was motiviert euch weiter zu
machen
na ja das ist unser leben die kunst und
die musik ist unser elixier also
letztendlich das ist das was wir seit
vielen jahrzehnten machen was uns
ausmacht und ich meine wir haben als
band uns ja auch was aufgebaut sind also
lassen wir uns natürlich von sum
pandemie knockout nicht nehmen ja also
die motivation ist ganz klar da wir
haben hoffnung wir haben zuversicht
jeder tag der vergeht wo wir nicht auf
der bühne stehen können wird dazu
beitragen dass die freude umso größer
sein wird
wenn wir uns wieder dürfen also wir wir
sind guter dinge und wir wollen auch
positive vibes rausschicken also nicht
resignieren nicht irgendwie aggressiv
werden oder in eine falsche richtung
denken es wird schon wieder gut werden
dass das haus und die größe raus ein
wunderbares schlusswort ja besser hätte
man es nicht auf den punkt bringen
können ihr übt weiter fleißig an neuen
songs und die werden euro fenstern auch
beglücken wenn sie arbeit sind vielen
dank alles gute für euch danke für das
gespräch und eine gute karriere erfolg
auch bei der demo da alles gut so und
euch natürlich auch vielen dank fürs
zuschauen und fürs mitmachen für eure
fragen und kommentare wir wünschen euch
einen schönen freitagabend und ein
hoffentlich schönes und gesundes
vielleicht auch erholsames wochenende
bis zunächst schotter